hey guys what's up the big news that
broke last night is that the new bitcoin
legal defense fund is officially
launched what do i mean well obviously
when there's open source software being
built the developers they don't work for
a corporation they don't necessarily get
paid a normal salary like you would at a
corporation and so ultimately those
individuals they're basically individual
contributors to this open source project
that leaves them susceptible to all
sorts of legal pressure what do i mean
well if you were to be a software
developer at a place like facebook or
google or amazon and anyone wanted to
come after you legally for the work that
you were doing those companies have
internal counsel external accounts they
have big balance sheets and they can
help protect you from those local
pressures when you're open source
developer that isn't necessarily true
there's someone out on your own and so
last night there was an email that went
out to the bitcoin developer list from
jack dorsey himself an academic and the
chain code labs co-founder all coming
together and saying we are going to
start the bitcoin legal defense fund
that's a non-profit that's going to
provide funding to those open source
developers or people working on open
source bitcoin projects what their idea
here is that's going to be staffed by
volunteers and also by part-time lawyers
and ultimately they're going to help
people devise legal defenses they're
going to pay for outside counsel to help
you find outside counsel and literally
they're going to spend their time trying
to get you to not worry about the legal
pressure that you're receiving if you
are a bitcoin developer who has come
under legal pressure and instead they
want to free you up so you can spend
your time focused on something more
important which is contributing to
bitcoin other bitcoin related open
source projects i generally think this
is a pretty good idea i think that it'll
be very very well received in the
community what i found interesting was
that the
announcement also explicitly said
they do not need more funding maybe in
the future they will but it is being
funded right now and so either that
means that the three individuals who are
gonna be on the board the bitcoin legal
defense are contributing enough capital
to go ahead and cover it or they've
already raised other capital into the
vehicle and over time we may learn who
that's from but ultimately bitcoin
developers are the heartbeat of bitcoin
they are the ones who are writing the
code they are the ones who are
ultimately making sure that this open
source project is able to grow to global
adoption so the idea of providing legal
services and free of charge via the
bitcoin legal defense fund is a great
idea kudos to jack and everyone else for
doing this i hope to see more and more
people starting to realize that there's
things that you can do whether you're
technical or not to help contribute to
the success of bitcoin over the coming
decades